once again I'm not hitting the panic
button I think for us it's just you know
we know the problem we know we have to
you know be better we just have to do
better and when you play a great team
you have to eliminate mistakes you just
have to we know exactly what we need to
do we need to play well we need to do
our job you should every play
that's Baker Mayfield after Monday
night's loss to the 49ers and the Browns
take a dip in the power rankings let's
get to this week's listing Chris I'm
gonna start with the top 10 as I always
do and the people on radio who are
following along you can take notes if
you would like number one the Patriots
number two the Saints up 1 after winning
against Tampa on Sunday Seahawks make a
three spot climb to number three Packers
make a three spot climb to number four
Chiefs down 3-2 number five here are the
49ers a six spot jump all the way up to
the sixth position Rams down to to
number seven bills up one to eight
Cowboys down five to nine and the Ravens
make a one spot climb to number 10 what
do you think well okay
not a whole lot wrong here I think
you're disrespecting the 49 are still at
six
I think the 49ers you could very easily
make them two or three I think it's
legitimate like there's no doubt about
it at this point it's one of the best
defenses in football one of the best
offenses in football and they've had
some really dominant wins well we'll see
what they do against the Rams that's
their opportunity to make an even bigger
jump I think if they thump the Rams and
we're gonna be doing the joint pft p.m.
Chris Sims on button podcast tomorrow
both will make our picks for that game
and I've gone back and forth on that one
yeah
because I think the Rams are gonna be in
desperation mo right and I think we're
gonna feel a little differently about
the 49ers if they would lose that game
on Sunday they're not going to go
undefeated the question is how will they
handle losing a game will they respond
by winning two or three or four in a row
or will they lose another one right
after that let's look at the second ten
okay goals are up from 13 to 11 the
Lions are up - even though they didn't
play to number 12 that's what happens
when the teams in front of you lose the
Panthers made a six spot climb to number
13 Bay and I went with a three-way here
why I've checked telling you why okay go
ahead check out I'll take the rest of
the segment the Bears the Raiders and
the Vikings are all tied for 14 because
the Vikings beat the Raiders then the
Bears beat the Vikings then the Raiders
beat the Bears so how do I put any of
them above the other I don't know it's
week six figure it out and rank them I
don't know we don't have much happen
just because it has in three weeks ago
doesn't mean you have to stay true to
this week teams get better week to week
ranked them I mean geez holy cow what a
wimp you become okay really you think
that ever stops me do you not know me
very well how would you rank those three
teams right now I think I would rank
them I would have gone probably after
what I've seen the last few weeks I
would have gone Raiders Vikings Bears I
think that would be the way I would have
ranked those three teams and just so
wait a minute go ahead do you understand
what the reaction would have been
the Raiders ahead of the Vikings even
though the Vikings beat the Raiders and
the Vikings ahead of the Bears yeah and
though the Bears beat the Viking right I
get that but that was three weeks ago
when the Raiders lost to the Vikings
they have now gone on the road and beat
the Colts in Indianapolis and beat the
Bears in London and the Vikings in the
meantime had a crap game in Chicago and
Chicago didn't even play that great in
that crap game either let alone playing
like crap and getting their butts
whooped last week against the Oakland
Raiders so for week six right now I just
can't believe it I thought I knew you I
thought I did but a three-way tie at 14
men you are really becoming weak in your
old age I can't believe it here's the
thing thank you very much of that I've
never even had a two-way tie that I can
remember and it may be the old age it's
keeping me from remembering but I just
couldn't figure out how best to separate
those three teams and it really is
amazing
consecutive Sundays you had Vikings beat
the crap out of the Raiders Bears
suffocate the Vikings and then the
Raiders take down the Bears a strange
sort of around Robin Colts were number
17 up from number 24 after beating the
Chiefs I can't put them a whole lot
higher than that because I'm still
remembering that loss at home to the
Raiders that really that I'm still mad
about that one because as I said last
week that's one of those picks we make
Chris where we say we feel good about
this one
yeah it blows up it's like it's hard
enough to pick the games that we don't
know what the hell is gonna happen
it's nice to be able to have a few games
every week that you feel good about and
that's when we felt good about and we
shouldn't have no eat while I put
Washington at 32 even though the
Dolphins didn't play and they were 32
after Jay Gruden and everything else
Washington is now number 32 below the
Dolphins and those two teams play us a
nice weekend
Wednesday's draft right after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports